MALE SPEAKER: I'm
pleased to introduce
Jenny Lawson, otherwise
known as The Bloggess.
Jenny's former book, "Let's
Pretend This Never Happened,"
was a number one New
York Times Bestseller.
And her current book,
"Furiously Happy,"
has already been named one of
the best humor books of 2015
by Amazon.
I have to admit, being up
here in front of all of you
makes me a little bit anxious.
But it will lessen shortly.
However, there's
another type of anxiety
that only increases over time.
It may be crippling or
lead to other dark places.
Jenny's visited those
places, and she's
determined to live the
rest of her life a bit
more happy because of them.
And she's written
that in her book.
It's a journey full of fun,
unexpected, and sometimes
serious events.
If you're like me
after reading it,
you may want to tell
your friends about it.
On the other hand,
as Jenny says,
if you don't like the
book, then maybe you're
just not crazy
enough to enjoy it.
Either way, you win.
Please join me in giving a
warm welcome to Jenny Lawson.
[APPLAUSE]
JENNY LAWSON: So first
of all, I'm gonna curse.
So I'm going to tell
you that right now.
So just be prepared.
Secondly, usually
I spend my lunch
having Google entertain me,
so this is fucking weird.
[LAUGHTER]
JENNY LAWSON: This is
like weird opposite day
and it's freaking me out.
Also, when I told my husband
that I was going to be here,
he said, oh, you should check
out the driverless cars.
And I was like, I don't even
know what you're talking about.
He was like, oh these
driverless cars.
And I was just like,
that's a terrible idea.
So I'm just telling
you right now.
I think maybe y'all
aren't in control of that.
So good job, because driverless
cars, I had one of those,
and it hit people.
If you don't put it completely
in park, it's not good.
You can get tickets.
And also I thought it would
be really strange to have
a driverless car-- and
you have to forgive me,
because I absolutely know
nothing about them except
the word "driverless
car"-- words--
but I hate to drive because
it makes me very anxious,
and so my husband
always drives me.
And I think it would be really
uncomfortable driving in a car
where there wasn't a
driver constantly cursing
at everyone else, because
that's how I know that I
someone's taking care of me.
And also when he's
always driving,
and he's like, well, where
do you want to go eat lunch?
And I'm like, oh, let's
go get Mexican food.
And he's like, nope.
So basically I would get a
driverless car that would say
like, where do you want to go?
And I'm not going
to take you there.
I'm going to make
you feel comfortable.
So I would say, first
off-- actually it's
not first, because I've
already been talking.
First off, I did not take
my ADD medicine today.
Probably pretty obvious, but
I'm going to try and focus.
I did take my anxiety medicine,
but taking my anxiety medicine
without taking my ADD medicine
makes me a little bit sleepy.
And then it's rainy, which
makes me totally sleepy.
I don't know how you
guys are awake ever.
And also the entire time
I'm like, look, rain!
Rain!
Because in Texas
we don't get this.
And everybody else is
like, ah, fucking rain.
So first of all,
good job on the rain,
and also good job on
seasons, having seasons.
That's a great thing.
We don't have that in Texas.
I am going to do a reading,
and this is literally
a page and half.
But that way you
can say, oh yeah,
I've been to a Jenny
Lawson reading.
I'm stepping on a
lot of wires here
and I might get electrocuted.
I'm sure it will be fine.
It'll be OK.
So I'm going to--
let's see-- I'm
going to skip that one,
which is a little bit dark.
Let's do this one, which
is-- and I will preface this
by saying, just in case
you have no idea who I am,
that's totally OK.
I am weird and slightly--
more than slightly-- off,
and I write weird
things on the internet,
and sometimes in books.
And weirdly enough,
people actually like them.
And I actually just found
out that this strange book
is on the "New York Time"'s
list for the seventh week
in a row, which is very
weird because you look at it
and it's like, Mindy Kaling
and that asshole O'Reilly.
And it's all these
people that you're
like, oh, I know that person.
I know that person.
I hate that person.
And then there's a dead
raccoon, so that's-- actually
that's kind of nice.
So "I Found a Kindred Soul, and
He Has a Very Healthy Coat."
A few weeks ago, I was at the
pharmacy picking up my meds,
and I'm starting into
the drive through window
and thinking about how awesome
it is to live in a world
where you can pick up
drugs in a drive through.
And that's when I noticed
something strange next
to the pharmacist's register.
And I don't know if you
can see this picture,
but this is an open box
of milk bone dog biscuits.
And I thought, well that's odd.
But maybe someone
returned them because they
were stale or
something, and then I
thought it was even odder
that someone would realize
the dog biscuits had gone
stale, because dogs usually
aren't very good at
not eating cookies
even if they're fairly shitty.
I mean, dogs eat used
diapers if you let them,
so I'm pretty sure
none of them are
saying no to eating cookies, but
then the pharmacist came back.
And while he was
ringing me up he
reached over and picked up a
handful of broken dog biscuits
and ate them.
I thought, wait.
Am I high right now?
Is he high?
Am I being tested?
Should I say something?
But I didn't, because I'm
pretty sure that you're not
supposed to accuse
the man giving you
drugs of eating dog food.
And then I signed for the
drugs and then I drove away.
And I thought to
myself, is it possible
that he accidentally
ate the dog biscuits?
Or maybe someone is always
stealing his food at work
so he decided to put his
tasty human cookies, maybe
for humans, not out of
humans, into a [INAUDIBLE] box
to keep them safe.
Or maybe he just likes
to entertain himself
by seeing if people will
stop him and say, dude,
you're eating dog food.
Those would be good
people probably.
I'm not one of those people.
But then I spent the whole day
thinking, why the dog biscuits?
So I went back today to ask,
but the dog biscuits were gone
and the dog biscuit
eating guy was also gone.
And I thought, can I
ask this pharmacist
if the other pharmacist
who eats dog food
is around because I really
need to know this story?
And the answer is no.
No, I can't.
But I still really want
to know because I suspect
that I would be great
friends with this guy,
because anyone who would hide
crackers in a dog food box
seems like someone I'd
want to hang out with.
Although someone who
eats dog food for fun
seems slightly
more questionable.
Except now I'm wondering if
maybe milk bones are really
delicious, and he's just
a genius who discovered
really cheap cookies.
Cookies you don't have to
tell your judgemental vet
about when your dog gets in the
pantry and eats all of them.
You did still have to
call the vet, though,
when your cat has eaten a toy,
which consists of a tinkle bell
and feather and a poof ball,
all tied together with twine.
This is actually
happened to me once,
and it was the worst
because the vet told me
I would have to ply
my cat with laxatives
in order to make the
toy pass through easily.
And then inspect his
poop to make sure
that the toy had passed,
because otherwise they would
have to do open cat surgery.
And then it finally
did start to pass,
but just the first part
with the tinkle bell.
And the cat's freaking out,
because he was running away
from the tinkle bell, which was
hanging out of his butthole.
And I called the vet, and he
said to definitely not pull
on the twine, because
it can pull out
his intestines, which would
be the grossest pinata ever.
And so instead, I just ran up
to the cat with some scissors
to cut off the tinkle bell,
which impressively was still
tinkling after seeing the
things no tinkle should ever
have to see.
And I think probably
the cat was running away
both because of the
tinkle bell and also
because I was chasing
it with scissors,
screaming let me help you.
If I was good friends with that
dog food eating pharmacist,
I would have called him to tell
him all about the tinkle bell
issue, because I think he
would have appreciated it.
But I never found
him again, because I
was worried that if I ever
asked to see the dog food eating
pharmacist, the other pharmacist
would stop giving me drugs.
This all feels a
bit discriminatory,
but I can't explain exactly why.
[APPLAUSE]
Shortest reading ever.
So I've heard that this is
the part where we do Q&A.
So if you have questions,
awesome, and if you don't, I'll
just make shit up.
So whatever.
So raise your hand if
you have questions.
Or just yell, or I don't know
what y'all do at Google--
maybe you've
[INAUDIBLE] lights up.
This is a really awesome
place, by the way.
So I saw scooters
on the way here.
Are those real or is
that just like a joke?
Do you really use the scooters?
Can I get a scooter
on the way out?
OK, and then I've also
heard that you have a boat
that people have meetings on?
OK, do you have a tree house?
AUDIENCE: We have a nap room.
JENNY LAWSON: Oh my god,
you have a nap room?
OK, well that's sort of close.
But here's what I would like.
I would like for you guys to
build some sort of tree fort,
and then up in a tree fort,
it's also a blanket fort.
And it's filled with pillows
and cats, and lasagna.
And I will be your
writer in residence,
and I will just live up there.
And if you're having a
bad day, you can come up.
And we can put your
head on my lap,
and I'll just pat your head and
go, poor bunny, it's all right.
And then we all win.
It's gonna be the
best, oh my gosh.
So anyway, I know you guys are
really fast-- so, tomorrow, OK?
So yes, but that on your
list of things to do.
But aside from that--
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
JENNY LAWSON: Sorry, yes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So in one of
your stories you reference
a fictional horse
named Pony Danza.
JENNY LAWSON: Yes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
how close you've
gotten to convincing
the rest of your family
to live with horses?
It happens to be a
lifelong dream of my wife,
and I'm also starting to
understand a little bit.
JENNY LAWSON: Everyone
should own a Pony Danza.
So if you haven't read-- so
I have a very severe anxiety
disorder-- depression,
avoidant personality disorder,
and a host of other things.
But anxiety disorder is the
one that really plagues me,
the one that I've had to
take the most medicine,
and therapy, all
that stuff for it.
And so I looked into getting
an anxiety service companion,
because I knew when I went on
book tours-- when I'm at home,
I stay home.
I'm super hermitty.
I do not leave.
I don't even leave my desk.
Like the mailman comes,
and I put my feet up
because I'm like, don't look
at me through the window.
I'm not here.
I don't exist.
So I was like, I need
to get a service animal.
And I have all my cats,
but one of my cats
has explosive
traveler's diarrhea.
And I was like, that's
not going to be calming me
on an airplane.
And so I was like, I'll
call around and find out,
because I have a dog, Dorothy
Barker, and I was like,
maybe I can teach
Dorothy Barker to be.
And it turns out, by
the way, that my dog has
anxiety disorder.
Jesus.
Like, ugh.
I get it.
Now I get why I was
attracted to this dog.
But then I called the
place that certifies,
and I called my shrink, and she
was like, this is who you call.
And they will set you up and see
if this is a good fit for you.
And they have to be
specially trained.
And when I called there,
they said well, first you
can't use cats as
service animals,
because they are not
good service animals,
because they're assholes.
And I get it.
It's probably true.
But she was like,
the two animals that
have been actually approved
as actual service animals
are dogs and ponies.
And I was like, ponies?
And she was like,
oh yeah, seriously.
Ponies are very, very smart and
recognize when you are anxious,
and they respond in the same
way that any trained service
animal would.
And so I said, I think
I need to get a pony
and take him with me
when I go to work,
and he'll just
stand in the aisle.
And I'll braid his mane, and
I'll name him Pony Danza.
And he'll be my medicinal
pony, and they can not
throw you off the plane,
because I have a disability.
This is my service horse.
And I was so excited about it.
And so I called, and I
called different places,
and they were like, oh yeah,
we can set you up with one.
And I was like, so what do I do?
Do I put it in the backyard?
And they were like no, it
lives in the house with you.
It's already potty trained.
But it's like a large litter
box basically is what you have.
And my husband was like,
OK, no, for several reasons.
First of all, I'm the one
who changes the litter,
and I'm not changing
the litter of a horse.
And secondly, I know you, and
you cannot stop with just one.
You will become
crazy horse lady,
and we'll have 18
horses in bed with us
at night, like we're
all [INAUDIBLE].
So so far he still says no,
but I think it's gonna happen.
I think it's eventually
going to happen,
just I need to find
the right Pony Danza.
But you don't run into
a lot of stray ponies.
You find a stray
cat, they're like,
OK, I guess you can keep it.
So what I need to do is I need
to find a pony and let it go.
And then find it again,
and be like, but Victor,
nobody wants this pony.
Oh my god, we should keep it.
It'll totally work.
Sorry, that was a really
long way to end a story.
The answer is no.
I don't have a horse.
Next question, if there is one.
Look, it's just an
empty microphone.
It's the microphone that's
scary, that's what it is.
AUDIENCE: I asked the
internet for questions,
because I was too
anxious for one.
But nobody's asked one yet.
That's really shitty.
When you're feeling
really shitty,
and you don't want
to do anything,
how do you stay motivated
to actually blog craziness,
like get up and do it?
JENNY LAWSON: That is
a really good question.
Honestly, and I wish I had
a better answer to that,
is the answer is I don't.
When I'm having--
especially when I'm
in the middle of a depressive
episode-- and my depression
comes and goes, it's
strictly chemical.
It's a serotonin thing.
But when it comes to
true depressive episodes,
I usually have a couple a
year, and when they hit,
I cannot do anything at all.
My only goal is
just to stay alive,
and to remind myself
depression lies.
I'm supposed to be here.
Everything my head is
telling me about how
everybody would be better off
without me, that's not true.
And it's going to be OK.
And just keep breathing.
And every day I wake up
like, is it gone yet?
No, but maybe tomorrow.
And I've given myself
permission to have
those weeks of
survival, and instead
of feeling like
I'm a failure, I'm
just laying here for two weeks
watching "Dr. Who" on repeat
instead of being like,
what a loser I am.
Instead I think, I'm surviving.
And there are so many people
who don't survive depression.
It can be fatal in a lot
of cases, and the fact
that every single day I
wake up and I'm like, well,
I'm still alive.
And I'm still breathing, and I
might even take a shower today.
And those are the victories
you have to celebrate.
When I was writing
just my blog, I
was very afraid of
talking about the fact
that I had depression
and anxiety.
And I definitely think
the stigma's still there.
It's not as bad as it was
seven years ago maybe,
when I came out about it.
And when I wrote
about it, in my family
there's lots of mental
illness, and in my family
you do not talk about it.
It's very, this is your
own personal secret,
and nobody knows.
And it's not until you grow
up and you're like, oh,
that's the reason why
that person disappeared,
because they were in
the mental institution!
I did think it was sort
of strange that they
just disappeared for
awhile and came back
and kept talking about
electroshock therapy.
Whatever, that's fine.
So I was the first person in
my family to come out about it,
and they were very supportive.
And they were like, you
do what's right for you.
Don't drag us into this.
And also just be
careful, because you
don't know how people are
going to react to this.
But I felt like I did have the
choice because I was writing,
and I typically write funny,
weird, irreverent stuff.
And during those
periods, when I knew
that I was going to
have this downtime
and never be able
to really focus,
I would have this
backlog of drafts.
And I would post those
instead, and say, there you go.
And I would approve
comments, and the comments
would be like, oh,
you're so funny.
You have such a great life.
And at the same
time, I'm just laying
there thinking like, I haven't
showered in three days.
I cannot make myself eat
soup, because I feel unworthy
of soup.
And I thought, I'm creating
this false history,
and so that's when I decided
I would be upfront about it,
and just say it.
And instead of people
running from me,
I had thousands of people who
came out and said, me too.
I thought I was the only one.
I thought I was the
only one who felt
like an impostor or a
fraud, or worthless.
And what's really
amazing about that
is that in the time since I
first came out with that post,
I had some people who've come
up to me and who have said,
I was actively in the process
of planning my suicide,
and I decided to
stop and to get help.
Not because of what you
wrote, but because I
saw thousands of people
responding to you,
and saying me too, me too.
I feel the same way.
And I realized if all
these people feel that way,
then obviously depression
is lying to us,
and that this is not something
that I am going through myself,
just completely alone.
And so I decided to get
help, and now here I
am, and here are my kids,
or here are my parents.
Here are all these
people who had no clue
that I was going through this.
And I wish I could go back
and tell all the people who,
especially anonymously, who
just shouted out into the void
and said, me too, I
feel the same way.
But that single act of just
shouting out into the darkness
may have saved someone's life.
That may have been
that one comment
that actually pushed someone
into saying, OK, all right.
I'm going to do that.
I'm going to get help.
So it's amazing the
way that each of us
touches other people in ways
that we can not possibly
imagine.
And I think it's just really
good to stop every once
in a while and just think.
The world would be a
worse place without you.
It would.
You bring so much more
wonderful things into your life,
than you will ever, ever know.
And you affect the world
in such great ways.
AUDIENCE: So as
a newer fan-- you
may actually talk about this
on your blog and in your books,
but I'm very curious about
humor as a coping mechanism
for mental illness
and depression.
I ask in particular because
I've noticed a lot of comedians
for instance--
and I think you're
by far the funniest-- if you see
interviews with them where they
talk about their home lives,
or their married lives,
or their [INAUDIBLE] lives,
or any number of things,
they're basically some of
the most unhappy people who
I've ever, ever encountered.
And I really started
thinking about this again,
because my best friend growing
up attempted suicide last year.
Thankfully he's gotten
help, but he laughed
the most, made the most jokes.
We had the most
laughing sort of times.
And at first I was
really surprised.
But then I started
trying to think about it,
and I thought, well
maybe that's why.
That's why he was one of
the funnier people I knew,
is that was just how he was
dealing with a lot of issues.
So I was wondering if you
could talk about that little.
JENNY LAWSON: That's a
really good question.
I don't know who it
was that said it,
but comedy equals
tragedy plus time,
and it really is true,
except that for a lot of us,
we don't have time.
I'd say we're like, just go
straight for the tragedy.
I think there is something
so wonderful about taking
something frightening
and horrifying and awful
and laughing at it.
It turns it from this enormous,
big monster into something
smaller, into something
that you can look at,
and suddenly you're not
as intimidated by it.
I think there are lots of
different ways of coping,
but for me, humor is absolutely
the way that I do it.
And I actually do it
for-- I do it at funerals.
I do it in completely
inappropriate places,
and I do it anytime I'm
having to deal with something.
I have rheumatoid arthritis,
and I had a miscarriage,
and all sorts of stuff.
And when it comes
right down to it,
the moments that were
the most human to me
were the moments when I
could look back and think
of something funny
that came from that.
And laugh, because laughter is
such a universally human thing.
I don't know if you
follow me on Twitter.
For the last week,
I wrote this tweet
just as I was
leaving the airport.
And I was getting on
the plane, and the lady
handed me my ticket, and she
said, have a great flight.
And I said, thanks, you too.
And so I tweeted that, and I
was like I can never come back
to this airport again.
And it was just a throwaway
sort of thing, but what happened
was I landed, and
there were thousands
of people who were like,
oh, you think that's bad?
And they started sharing
their terrible things,
and they were-- I'm not
even kidding with you,
they were so funny.
I am not a laugh out
loud kind of person.
I was laughing so hard.
First of all, I had tears
rolling down my face.
Hotel security had to
be called, because they
thought that something
had happened to me.
And they were like,
are you OK, ma'am?
Has someone hurt you?
And I'm like puffy,
swollen-faced tears,
and I'm like, no, this is
how I look when I'm happy.
Are you alone?
Can you do a welfare check?
It's just me on in internet.
But what's really
fantastic is, first of all,
I retweeted so
many of the people.
Like some people had
to put me on mute,
because their notifications got
blown up and they were like,
I'm not allowed to get anymore
notifications today now.
Thanks very much.
But so many people followed
it, and got into it,
and just loved
the universal idea
that once you laugh at the
most horrifyingly embarrassing,
terrible thing, that
it becomes something
that you are a part of
laughing at it instead
of it possessing you.
Plus, you would see so many
people responding to that one
person who would just
shout out and be like,
one time I thought there
was a bug in my pants.
And then I started
to shake it out
and it was
yesterday's underwear.
And it was in front
of everyone I knew.
And they would write
like, oh god, why?
Why did this happen?
And a thousand other people
would write and it'd be,
oh I had that happen to me.
But I thought I was
the only person who
would do it-- me too.
And they would get it, and all
these people were saying, OK,
so I just shared the most
mortifying moment of my life,
and it just got
favorited 80,000 times.
What?
That's what I'm going
to be known for?
I'll take it.
I'll take that.
And I think because there is
such a universal thing, shame,
and fear, and embarrassment,
and mortification,
and there's such a
wonderful healing
process of laughing at that.
And actually, weirdly
enough, the "New York Times"
picked it up, and
they were like,
oh, let's do a story about this.
And I was like, OK.
And they were like, oh,
we want to talk to you.
And I was like, I don't like
to talk to people on phones,
because I'm weird.
But you can send me an email.
So I just wrote and was
like, yeah, this happened
and it was funny.
And they were like, well,
let's bring in a psychiatrist.
And so the bottom part
was a psychiatrist saying,
this is the reason
why this is funny.
I was like, yeah, OK, whatever.
But I thought it
was so great that it
was a story about tweets,
and they were like,
let's bring in
the professionals,
because what the fuck
is going on here?
But anyway, yeah.
Sorry.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I thought that
it would be a great idea
to ask you for advice.
And I have impostor
syndrome, and I
know a lot of other people
in this room do too,
and so my question is, what
do I do when they find me?
[LAUGHTER]
JENNY LAWSON: Such
a good question.
So first of all, I'll
answer your question
and then I'll go back
to talking about it.
So what do you do
when they find you?
You say, I'm so glad to
be home, because everyone
feels like that.
And the people who
are going to find you
are all of us, who are going
to say, oh, I have that too.
I have that constant fear
that at any moment somebody
is going say, oh,
you're not that smart.
Or you're not that funny.
Or you're not-- you
have just weaseled
your way into pretending that
you're a human and you are not.
I know you.
What I think is so interesting
about impostor syndrome
is that when I started
writing about it,
so many people would respond
and say, oh I didn't even
know there was a word for it.
But yes, I have the same issue.
What is really amazing is
how many people I absolutely
adore and respect who emailed
me and said, I have this too.
And I was like, what the fuck?
How in the world?
When I did the book trailer
for this book, I was like,
I don't want to
do a real trailer.
Let's just do something
where people hold up signs
and they say, "I'm
broken because,"
and the other side says "but
I'm furiously happy because."
Because you can't stop the
fact that we're all broken,
but you can look
at the good things
that can come from the
brokenness, or the things
that we have inside of us.
So I basically just went
out on Facebook and said,
do you feel comfortable
sharing this?
And one of the people who
said, I really want to share,
was Pat Rothfuss.
And if you don't know him,
he's a fantastic writer,
and you should read
everything he's ever written.
He's so, so good.
He's one of my
absolute favorites.
And he struggles with
impostor syndrome,
I think even more than I do.
And his that he held up--
and I think most people just
looked at him and they
were like, oh, who's
this bushy-faced stranger,
instead of being like,
oh, this is this super
important, fantastic, science
fantasy author who
people adore and love.
And he held his up,
and it said, "I'm
broken because I feel
like a failure every day."
And then when he
turned around it said,
"But I'm furiously happy because
some days I can string together
five perfect words."
And I thought that was such
a wonderful thing, because it
was all about recognizing
the fact that we are slow,
and we are human, and we all
struggle in different ways,
and we compare
ourselves to people.
I always compare myself to
Stephen King or Neil Gaiman.
They get on a plane and then the
plane lands, and they're like,
I wrote a book while
I was on the plane.
Here it is.
It's a bestseller.
And I'm like ugh,
how do you do this?
Because it took 14 years
to get my second book out.
And I think really
what I've learned
is the importance of realizing
we all work at our own speed,
and we all have different
ways of recognizing
what success looks like.
And recognizing it.
Actually, one of the things
I had to work with in therapy
was with my first book,
I was really afraid
that the book would
be successful.
Because I was like, I don't
know what that would look like,
and I don't know what
that would mean for me.
And I don't think
I could handle it,
I think I would be very
embarrassed and uncomfortable.
And even today I have a hard
time when people are like,
oh my god I love your book.
And I'm like, no you don't.
You really don't.
You should get out more.
Or when they're
like, oh my gosh,
I'm so excited I
get to meet you.
And I'm like, I'm going
to disappoint you.
I'm sorry.
I have nothing for you.
And then I have to
just remind myself
that, just like everybody else,
we all feel like failures.
And if you don't
feel like a failure,
you're probably a sociopath.
And not that that's
necessarily a bad thing.
My husband has some super
sociopathic tendencies.
He's very successful.
In fact, most really successful
people are kind of sociopaths,
and that's what makes
them good at their job.
So if you're sitting here and
you're like, what the fuck
is she talking about? you're
probably really successful,
and a sociopath.
But that's OK.
You're probably
not a psychopath,
and those are the
ones that kill people.
Don't do that.
That's my advice.
This is all really good advice.
You should be writing that down.
Don't kill people.
Oh my gosh, it's brilliant.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First I wanted to say thank you.
I never heard your name
before this talk was announced
last week, but when I realized
you were The Bloggess I
put two and two together.
Because between your blog
and Allie Brosh's "Hyperbole
and a Half," my best
friend back in Canada
found the courage
to similarly write
some of her awful experiences
of terrible clinical depression
and so on, and share that.
And although there's
probably about ten of us
right now that read her blog
and comment and so on right now,
I wanted to preemptively ask
you that-- the internet comment
sections tend to be
full of vitriol and vile
from pseudo-anonymous
people-- and I was wondering
what your experience was there.
How you deal with that,
and maybe I can help
prepare Jess for that
first godawful experience.
JENNY LAWSON: So I do
sometimes get nasty comments.
I think we tend to
overuse the word "troll,"
because a lot of
times we'll say troll
and really it's just a critic.
And there is a difference.
I'll have people
who will just be
like, I don't think this is very
funny, or something like that.
And some people will be like,
oh, what a terrible troll.
And I'm like, not really.
Like, it's probably my mom.
Whatever, just giving me
feedback, that's fine.
For me, though, there's a
couple different things.
First of all, my
Kismet, or something?
Whatever my blog
software is, it catches
the first time somebody
leaves a comment--
it has to be approved.
And then after I've
approved it once,
then you can leave
a comment forever.
So if somebody
typically wants to leave
a really horrid comment,
and I do get them--
and for me a horrid
comment is, I
think you should
be raped to death.
Which, weirdly, I get
that not uncommonly.
Like, more than once.
And I'm like, is
this the same person?
I don't think so.
A little confusing.
But what happens is, it
gets caught in moderation.
And those people want to see
you cry, like that's their job.
They really, really want that.
And so what I do is I go in
and I approve their comment,
and I leave their name and
all their information and all
that stuff.
But I change their
comment from "you whore,
you should be stabbed" to "I
wish I could be just like you.
You're my hero."
[LAUGHTER]
JENNY LAWSON: And it's lovely,
because they're constantly
refreshing because they want
to see your response, right?
And then they'll write
again, and they'll be like,
I never said that.
I never said anything like that.
And I'll change
that comment to "I
wish I could wear your
skin like a jacket."
I have never had anyone come
back more than three times.
And I think it's really, really
wonderful, because your blog is
your house.
And so I'm usually
entertained by it.
[LAUGHTER]
JENNY LAWSON: My other
one is, and this is one--
like that one, I have fun with.
But this one, is one's a little
petty, but still I do it.
Sometimes somebody will leave
a really, really long comment,
and it's almost
like a dissertation.
And it will be like, this sucks,
boring, puerile, blah blah
is the reason of the
civilization crashing.
And it'll be like, really
have to pull out a dictionary.
I don't even know
some of these words.
What?
And you can tell
that what they want
is they want it to be
approved so they can show it
to their friends,
and they'd be like,
yeah that girl that
was on front page
of [INAUDIBLE] for some reason.
Also, why am I on the
front page of [INAUDIBLE]?
I love you Drew, stop putting
me on the front page of
[INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE] I get lots
of great comments too,
but every time it's on
[INAUDIBLE], I'm always like,
it's not news.
My blog is not news.
But it will be this
long dissertation,
and you know that they
want it to be approved,
so they can show everybody
else and be like, see,
I took her down.
And I'll approve
the comment, and it
will be exactly the right
way-- except I'll go in
and I will misspell
several of their words.
[LAUGHTER]
JENNY LAWSON: Thank you.
And you know later they're
like, yeah, oh my god.
Oh my god.
[LAUGHTER]
JENNY LAWSON: And
then there's no way
they're going to be
like, yeah, check out
what-- they're going to be
like, no, just ignore that
altogether.
It's fine.
Let's talk about something else.
It's wonderful.
When the book came out, because
I have avoidant personality
disorder-- it's like social
anxiety disorder on speed--
whenever somebody will say
something bad to me on the blog
or something, usually
anything they've said,
I've already said
about myself way worse.
And so typically I'll
be like, actually
let me come over here, because
I've already insulted myself
in a much, much better way than
you did, and so let's do that.
But when the book came
out, it was the first time
that I didn't have control over
what happens with the reviews
and stuff like that.
And when the first book
out, before it actually
hit the stands, it got
reviewed from a trade review--
which I didn't even know
that that was a thing.
There's four houses that you
want to review your stuff,
and it's important or whatever.
And I had no idea.
I had no idea what anything was.
But I got this review, and
it was a really bad review.
Like so bad that I kind of
looked at it and was like,
was this even the right book?
Like oh god, oh my
god, it was so, so bad.
And I couldn't write for
about two weeks after that.
I couldn't write anything,
because all I could think of
was that review.
Even though my editor and
agent and everybody were like,
that's just one person.
That's not the whole house.
Just one person was
assigned that book.
They don't know you.
They may have just
glanced at it.
They got paid $20 for it.
It's OK.
But it really affected me.
And so I ended up getting other
people to read the reviews,
and tell me, here is
something that you
do need to be concerned
about for your next book.
And there's some other stuff
that you can just ignore,
which is really helpful.
What was also really helpful
is a couple months later,
the exact same trade
publication reviewed
the audiobook of the same
book, of "Let's Pretend This
Never Happened," and they
were like, a tour de force!
And I was like, it's
the same fucking book.
It is the same book, except
I read it out loud to you.
That's the only difference.
And that's when I realized
that it really does come down
to each individual person.
And some people will
come up and be like,
oh, I really don't
like your work.
First of all, that's weird,
because you don't have
to tell me-- like, that's fine.
But what I always
say is, it's OK.
It's not for everyone,
because it's not.
Because if you make
something that no one hates,
how boring would that be?
It would be toothless and awful,
and you would just be like,
oh yeah, I guess, whatever.
You almost want at least a
couple people to say, mm.
Mm.
I cannot believe that you just
said that you think that Jesus
should be classified as a
zombie because he came back from
the dead.
You want a couple
people to say, no,
that's not OK-- so that
everyone else who comes in says,
oh my god, I thought that too.
Why is that?
Why are we drinking
the blood of the god?
Are we vampires?
What's happening?
And then suddenly you're
like, oh, I'm with my people.
And you realize that maybe
those people, maybe it's
just like 0.01% of
the population who
thinks the same weird
stuff that you do,
but the wonder of the
internet is that-- instead
of when I grew up and I was
in this tiny little town
surrounded by tractors, and
I was like the one goth kid
in the middle of a cornfield.
And now I go out and I'm
like, oh, I found my people.
I'm not alone.
I'm completely not alone.
Even though it's
just that 0.01%,
we make such a difference.
That 0.01% is loud when
you get us all together.
Well not really loud, because
we're all kind of hermitty
and we're hiding
under our chairs.
But we take up a lot of
chairs, and we will make
you feel very uncomfortable.
And I think that is
extremely [INAUDIBLE].
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So I was
trying to figure out
what to do about that.
So I've been reading
the reblogs that you've
done of the Twitters
comments you've been getting.
It's like a perfect
minefield of amusement.
So it's like, I'll read 10
of them, and I'm like, OK.
They're OK.
And then I'll get the one-- and
it's just like all of a sudden.
I'm like, it's OK to
read this in public.
And then I start laughing
really, really hard,
and it's really embarrassing.
So I wanted to know
if you had any--
what do you do when you hit
a dry spell, from a writing
perspective?
Particularly when it's based
on that feeling of not being
good enough, or not
being able to accomplish
what you want to do, like
how do you handle that?
JENNY LAWSON: That actually
happens to me quite a lot.
And whenever I have a dry
spell or writer's block,
if it happens for a day or
two, I'm like, oh, that's OK.
It's gonna work.
It's not uncommon for me to
have a week where I cannot write
anything.
Nothing is funny.
Nothing is interesting, and
at a certain point I think,
I will never write again.
And I did that
before my first book,
all through my first book,
through my second book.
And you get to this point where
you start to realize, well,
it's always worked out before.
Eventually I'll have
something to say again.
One of the things
that I can say is
I think so often we think
that that there needs
to be a lot of material,
and if you're not constantly
entertaining people, that
they're going to go away.
And I don't think that
that's necessarily true.
I think, in a lot of
cases-- like Allie Brosh
is the perfect example.
She'll go a year
without writing.
And she's just like,
nope, I'm going in hiding.
And then she'll write something,
and everyone on the internet
is like, ah!
It's Allie!
She's back!
It's OK!
And I think that
people understand that.
They understand that you're
going to have those dry spells,
that everyone does.
And it's not just when
it comes to writing.
It's when it comes
to creativity,
or maybe it's about a project
that you're working on,
or maybe it's a painting,
or maybe it's everything
that you do-- especially if
you do it and you're like,
oh, I've got it.
I nailed it.
Oh, it's perfect.
And then you'll have that
week where nothing works
and you just think,
well, I guess that was
as good as it ever gets.
And then something happens.
And for me, it will
be like a single word,
or it will be a
conversation that I'm
having, and I will
just be like, shut up!
No one talk.
And I'll run to my computer.
And it really feels
like head constipation.
And suddenly you're
like, oh my god, finally.
I have not shit in weeks.
But that's what it feels like.
It's like oh my
god, I can do this.
I can totally do this.
And it's such a great thing.
And I think giving
yourself permission
to-- I always call it
refill your creative cup,
and that looks like different
things for different people.
And so, for me,
sometimes it means
I have to read all sorts of
funny blogs, and funny books.
Sometimes I just have
to watch TV for a week.
Sometimes I have to force
myself to get out of the house,
to do something.
But I just have to know
that, eventually, something's
going to happen, and
it's gonna click.
And I'm gonna be
like, oh I got it.
Oh, OK.
It's still there.
But just reminding
yourself that that is still
there is a good
thing, because it is.
MALE SPEAKER: I
just wanted to thank
you very much for
joining us today,
and we'll have signing
right over here.
[APPLAUSE]